what up space fam golden here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss another one piece video this
time about my boy shanks and his crew
and it seems like a fitting time to talk
about them since the new one piece film
red is coming out and it will be related
to our red hair yonko in this video
we'll be looking at shanks and his crew
i'm talking fights powers origins and
more so make sure to stay tuned for that
if you do enjoy these videos and want to
keep them coming you know what to do
chill the pirate king with it and smash
that like button with no mercy remember
smashing his pirate king energy and
passing is scared of rochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates let me know
who your favorite crew member of the red
hair pirates is in the comments and
while you wait for the next one piece
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos in all the anco warlords mythical
zones and much more link to that is in
the description and now without further
ado let's jump into its spoilers and all
our red-haired yonko is 199 centimeters
or six foot and six inches tall we know
he is a yonko with an over 4 billion
berry bounty and after recent events in
the manga he currently has the largest
active known bounty and even before that
he was quite possibly the most hyped
figure in the entire series when he does
show up he usually delivers in a big or
shocking way and that's made him a fan
favorite character despite the fact that
he doesn't show up in that many chapters
at all relatively speaking here's what
we know about this legend he was born 39
years ago in the west blue about 30
years ago he was an apprentice along
with buggy on gold d rogers crew at this
point he was already wearing the straw
hat that he got from roger and that he'd
go on to pass down to luffy kid shanks
was reading an article about whitebeard
with buggy and they were both upset that
it was an article about their crew since
they were raising so much ruckus
themselves there was that competitive
spirit between goldie rogers crew and
whitebeard's crew roger was happy to
read about it though and even saw an
opportunity wishing to meet with the new
samurai odin who was currently on
whitebeard's crew 24 years ago so when
shanks was about 15 goldie roger turned
himself in and was executed rayleigh
tells us that four years before that
roger was afflicted with a terminal
illness so shanks was around 11 at that
point it's interesting that while roger
was suffering from this incurable
illness that's exactly when they did the
impossible and conquered all of the
grand line raley says it was
specifically three years after his
diagnosis that they did this shanks
would have been 14 and it was made
possible in part by crocus the
lighthouse caretaker he was one of the
best doctors and he was able to lessen
roger's pain by the way if you want a
video completely devoted to roger and
his crew let me know in the comments
because this stuff is fascinating and i
can't believe i still didn't devote an
entire video to roger yet while on the
crew with fellow apprentice buggy the
two meaning shanks and buggy would butt
heads they argued stubbornly about stuff
like whether it is colder than north
pole or the south pole they irritated
rayleigh who'd hit them and tell them
who cares if they must know the answer
then they gotta go and find out for
themselves after this argument the crew
saw a ship and headed for them to fight
shank saw that buggy looked happy and
buggy said of course i'm happy a ship is
treasure for the taking shanks wasn't so
sure remarking hmm maybe you're right he
clearly wasn't as treasure obsessed as
buggy it's noteworthy though that even
as apprentices shanks and buggy carried
weapons and fought back to the
conversation in the flashback buggy
calls shanks and all the roger pirates
soft not knowing they would become the
number one crew in a year or few clearly
buggy thought shanks and roger were over
complicating the philosophy of a pirate
but that's what i love about one piece
everyone has their own definition of
what it means to be a pirate and i love
seeing them go after it whether it's
treasure power and or freedom but oda
makes a point of emphasizing how naive
buggy is here as soon as he finds his
first treasure map on a ship he
immediately hides it for himself and
assumes his fortune is as good as made
even though shanks is supposed to be
about 13 years old or younger in this
flashback depending on when exactly it
takes place he enjoys drinking and
partying with the other pirates and
having a good time while buggy keeps to
himself planning for his individual
future the two are clearly buddies
though and have broke conversations
where shanks tells buggy that he'll go
off on his own someday as captain of his
own ship he emphasizes that he'll make
time to see the world and do some
pirating along the way of course buggy
again views this as a soft answer still
even back then buggy can't help but
admit that shanks is a good fighter he
even says if he wasn't so soft he'd ask
shanks to be on his crew shanks of
course responds that he would never work
for buggy since they think too
differently at this point he says it's
better if they go their separate ways
since being a pirate is all about going
your own way i really like that
definition too buggy says that if they
ever cross paths on the high seas it'll
be a fight to the finish and shanks
agrees while still drinking saying
that's also what being a pirate is all
about man this dude meaning our shanks
is old beyond his years right here but
it's important that he realizes that if
you want to live your own way you also
got to be ready to fight to defend that
freedom since others may try to take it
from you this lets us know that even
back then he wasn't naive or only
looking at the nice things about being a
pirate shanks goes on to tell buggy that
they found a devil fruit and it seems to
be the first one the crew has found
based on the way they talk about it
roger says anyone who wants to can eat
it but they'll lose the ability to swim
buggy thinks only a fool would eat it
since there's tons of treasure on the
ocean floor and you can get it if you
can't swim but buggy gets more
interested when hearing that the fruit
is worth a fortune perhaps 100 million
berries buggy comes up with a plan he
will make it look like he ate the fruit
but actually he keeps the real one safe
hoping to sell it the rest of the crew
just assumes that the fruit wasn't ripe
or that the stories were lies he plans
to get a fortune with the fruit and map
and then he'll use it to put together
the cruelest pirate crew ever and steal
more treasure buggy sounds like a clown
male version of nami but anyways buggy
is clearly in a hurry to get himself
rich while shanks is much more laid back
enjoying the present as he goes shanks
ends up accidentally sneaking up on
buggy and the second time he does it
buggy accidentally swallows the fruit
that everyone already thought he
swallowed then as he's freaking out over
that his treasure map goes into the
water he jumps in for it but can't swim
shanks then jumps in to save his
crewmate clearly concerned based on his
actions and also the expression on his
face it's so funny how buggy uses this
story to justify why he hates shanks and
won't ever forgive him when everyone's
sane like luffy will come to the
conclusion that he should be grateful
that shanks saved his life shanks and
buggy also participated in the many
fights between the roger pirates and
whitebeard pirates and even whitebeard
during his meeting with shanks remarks
that they thought so many times that he
began to remember some faces among
roger's crew including the faces of
shanks and also buggy who he refers to
as that funny red-nosed kid in the same
meeting shanks says that they parted
ways at log town when roger was executed
and haven't met since however he did
invite buggy to come with him and join
his crew so he wasn't against being on
the same crew as buggy he just wanted to
be the captain just as buggy did as well
it shows how close they actually became
during their shared time as apprentices
another notable event happened 27 years
ago or when shanks was 12 he and buggy
along with the rest of the roger pirates
were confronted by shiki the golden lion
buggy was freaking out saying captain
roger our lives are more important just
do as the golden lion asks for the time
being end quote at this point buggy
already has his true powers and shanks
remarks you can't die no matter how many
times you get stabbed so what do you
care and quote crocus is on board at
this point too and is just fascinating
how calm shanks is while buggy the one
safer because of his powers is freaking
out like crazy shiki wants roger who
knows the location of the weapon that
can destroy the world to become his
right hand man but roger is not
interested not only is his time running
out he also has no desire to rule since
as he says what good is a pirate if he
can't do what he wants in other words
roger refuses to become hokage and do
tons of paperwork despite being vastly
outnumbered roger declines the offer and
when asked so your answer is that you
want to die today roger responds no my
answer is that i'm going to crush you
all roger was not pirate king yet and
shiki had the largest power fleet around
and this war came to be known as the
battle of ed war we actually see a 12
year old shanks right in front with
roger and rayleigh charging to battle
interestingly enough roger's ship was
saved by raging weather something we
usually associate with monkey d dragon
leading me to a bunch of questions that
we probably don't need to go over in
this video however one possibility is
that since buggy ate his fruit someone
else on the crew may have eaten a fruit
that controls the weather and that is in
the present day in the possession of
dragon because of this raging weather
half of shiki's fleet sank and shiki had
an unfortunate accident allowing roger
and by extension shanks to escape the
battle which was declared a draw we're
told in chapter 0 where these events
take place that about two years later
roger conquered the grand line and they
started calling him the pirate king then
his crew mysteriously disappeared and
after a year of being pirate king news
of his arrest broke out and shocked the
world shanks and buggy are shown crying
during roger's execution in chapter 0
and in the same chapter we are then
shown shanks meeting yasuo and asking
him to join the crew but the really cool
chapter zero aside it is during chapter
965 of the manga that we see one of the
battles that the roger pirates had
against the whitebeard pirates through
flashback this is about 26 years ago or
when shanks was about 13. again you get
a panicked buggy and the smiling shanks
as they find out whitebeard's ship is on
the far side of the island raja is also
excited saying you can only risk death
while you're still alive and his end is
nigh aka close anyways so there's
nothing to worry about it's also said
that this might be the last time they'll
ever meet whitebeard at this point odin
is on whitebeard's crew roger meets him
in combat before rayleigh can odin is
literally blown away by roger's attack
then roger and whitebeard clash before
their crews and their conquerors hockey
attacks are so strong the weapons don't
even come close to touching each other
the crews fought and the battle lasted
for three days and nights on the fourth
day they exchanged gifts showing each
crew's respect for the other at this
point blackbeard asks about shanks and
buggy and if they're apprentices how
crazy is it that we have three future
yonko right here it's remarked that
buggy and shanks have been around for
ages they don't look very tough but
they've got the attitude of grown men
hearing that said of even buggy shows
how far he's come in his apprentice
years meanwhile shanks and buggy talk
about blackbeard buggy says that
blackbeard didn't sleep a wing during
the ceasefire last night or the night
before shanks asks why not and buggy
responds they say he's never slept in
his life shanks thinks that's lucky and
he bets his life is twice as fun while
buggy has a completely different
interpretation buggy thinks shanks is
missing the point entirely saying that
blackbeard is a monster as usual one
looks at things in a more carefree fun
way while the other looks at things in a
more scared and panicked way ironically
though the story is not saying shanks is
right and buggy is wrong since as we'll
find out shanks will later realize that
blackbeard is a big deal just like buggy
was saying but more on that later roger
speaks with whitebeard and asks him to
let him borrow odin for a year odin can
read the poneglyphs and with him he's
sure that he can reach the final island
roger wants it so bad his crew even sees
him bowing his head toward whitebeard
and odin as he begs odin to come with
him for a year whitebeard was furious
since he valued family above all and he
felt like roger was trying to steal his
family however odin was intrigued he
wondered why he could read the letters
on ponoglyphs and why he came across
roger at this moment in time it seemed
like the universe was giving him a sign
finally after odin begged him for
permission whitebeard gave it thus odin
joined shanks and the roger pirates
roger even left behind a fortune worth
of stuff as thanks and even food
whitebeard though being such a good guy
said give them the food you fools don't
you dare let odyn's family go hungry end
quote baby momo hiyori and toki were
also traveling with the roger pirates
which kind of makes you think shanks
could have let seven year old luffy tag
along with him if you really wanted to
even iwarashi and nekomamushi joined
them as stowaways shanks and buggy are
shown frowning at one point with the
rest of the crew where the general
sentiment in the beginning seems to be
captain roger needs you odin but don't
just assume that we're going to accept
you as one of us and after all odin
comes from an enemy crew and the plan is
for him to only stay a year so this
makes sense pretty soon though we're
shown shanks buggy and the rest of the
crew coming around smiling and singing
odin's praises at one point odin finds
out from crocus that rogers probably got
a year to live at best roger just laughs
as odin freaks out we see them traveling
to sky island and shanks buggy and odin
are shown being shocked to see people
living in the sky they see that giant
golden bell and buggy wants to steal it
but roger says he doesn't have time and
buggy can come back and get it when he's
captain buggy we also find out that it
was easy for roger to find this stone
because it was full of strong voices
they also find out that the message
speaks of the ancient weapon poseidon
it's during this time while they were
going to a city of shipbuilders that we
see shanks and buggy arguing about what
pole is colder and rayleigh telling them
to shut it meanwhile roger is focused on
gathering all four road poneglyphs they
see tom the shipwright who build roger's
ship and both roger and shanks go in to
hug him kid frankie is present here too
while all these legends are passing
through the crew goes to fishman island
as well both roger and odin hear a voice
down in the depths before neptune shows
up newly crowned king neptune is
starting to think that his future
daughter could be the ancient weapon
poseidon thanks to a prophecy prophet
girl charlie also lets them know that
she'll be born in 10 years as the crew
moves on and we continue to see select
scenes we see one of shanks holding baby
momo's hand as they approach another
poneglyph when they get near wano toki
odin's wife falls ill they believe it is
because the exhaustion of her long
journey has finally cut up to her so she
must disembark on wano neko and inu are
gonna stay with toki and even odin says
he'll stay with toki as well but his
wife insists that he will go with roger
she encourages him by saying if you are
the type of man who stops now then i'm
getting a divorce gotta respect her and
how much she respects odin's dreams
after getting the info from the
poneglyph in wano they then go to zou
both odin and roger felt uncomfortable
here like something was watching them
here they find the final road poneglyph
along with the kozuki crest a young
pedro wants to join roger and the crew
but is told that his time to shine has
not come yet we see shanks being
concerned for roger asking if he's
alright at one point roger emerges from
his cabin and asks if they figured out
where they are sailing when it's made
clear that they have roger tells them
they're sailing for there right now he's
clearly conscious of how little time he
has left unfortunately buggy catches a
sudden fever before the crew leaves for
left tail he begs to go on the final
island but is not in any position to do
so shanks being the amazing guy he is
chooses to stay behind and care for his
crewmate odin can't tell if they are
best friends or mortal enemies shanks
tells them if he and buggy are gonna go
there they'll take their own ship
someday an exciting line which gets me
excited by the possibility of shanks and
buggy sailing together again one day and
the fact that they are both yonko now
would just make it all the sweeter we
then skip to after they have completed
the voyage everyone in the world is
going crazy over the fact that rogers
completed a full circumnavigation of the
globe since he was the first to ever do
it they say he's conquered the seas and
they call him the king of the sea and
the king of the pirates odin says they
learned the entire truth of the world
what the 100 year void is what the
people of the dr what the ancient
weapons are and so on odin also says in
the face of the vast treasure which was
very real indeed roger just laughed and
everyone else did too until tears sprang
from their eyes roger wished he'd been
born in joyboy's time saying that this
is quite a treasure he's left behind a
tale full of laughs as the first people
to reach the final island in 800 years
they dub it laugh tail when roger
returns from laughtale shanks goes to
him he asks roger something only to
start crying afterwards while gripping
on his pirate king coat the implication
is that roger doesn't have much time and
shanks doesn't want to see him go the
fact that shanks wasn't there though at
laughtale really separates him from that
older generation and sets him up as
someone who like roger can spend his
life seeking out the truth for himself
as well the birth of the king of the
pirates the man who achieved wealth fame
and power causes a world stir and the
world government purposely changes his
name to gold roger after finding out the
truth behind the d clan rayleigh says he
can understand why the world government
would want to hide goldie rogers true
name the world at large came to refer to
everything roger gained as the one piece
with shanks in the audience roger tells
his crew that it's been miraculous
seeing how far they've come once he
already knew he was going to die he has
nothing but gratitude for them all and i
must say in response to this shanks has
the most joy boy luffy-like grit of them
all it is at this point that roger
disbands the roger pirates he tells them
that someone will be born that will
surpass them which has to be referring
to luffy rogers says they were just too
early one of the reasons seems to be
because poseidon aka shirahoshi still
needed 10 years to be born and another
15 to grow despite the fact that his
time was running out quickly he was sure
that he would have a son it's settled
that roger will leave the ship first and
odin second after saying something to
rayleigh that made the dark king cover
his face with his hand roger waved
goodbye as shanks buggy and the rest
cried their eyes out his disease was in
its final stages they took odin home
next and he remarked that now wano must
open its ports before the day that
joyboy appears which we now know will be
luffy shanks and buggy cried when odin
left too and as we know shanks
eventually made his way to the execution
at logtown and was seen crying along
with buggy buggy declined the offer to
join shanks's crew this time and thus
shanks began his own individual rise
through the pirate world as the captain
of his own crew being shown to recruit
yasob first just as we saw him do in
chapter 0. he went to recruit the
skilled sniper 22 years ago aka when he
was 17 just like luffy was when he
officially started his pirating career
at some point between roger's execution
and the beginning of the series where he
inspires luffy shanks received his scars
from blackbeard in one piece episode
zero we see shanks meet yasuo and guess
what we don't see his left eye it's
strategically covered up it's like
they're going out of their way to show
shanks's right eye while covering up the
left one thus we can't confirm he
already had the scar but this does hint
at the possibility that shanks might
have gotten his scar from blackbeard
after roger's execution and before he
officially got crew members he tells
whitebeard later that he's fought
countless battles and received countless
scars but only one still aches and it's
the one blackbeard gave him he says he
didn't get those scars on an adventure
or in his fight with hawkeye he got it
from blackbeard and perhaps the most
important detail it wasn't because he
was careless so yes he might have been
very young when he got it he was younger
than 26 or 27 which is around how old he
was when he first made luffy's village
his base when the story starts and
shanks is around 27 we know that he'd
already been coming to the village for a
year although we don't know for certain
that luffy met him the first time he
ever came to the village before he lost
his arm for luffy we also know that he
had duels with mihawk whitebeard would
later tell him that his duel with mihawk
was still fresh in his memory that's
high praise from the so-called strongest
man in the world who clashed with the
king of the pirates himself on many
occasions we also know now that before
shanks would bring the gum gum fruit to
luffy aka 12 years before the current
events of the story his crew stole the
gum gum fruit from a government ship and
specifically from cp9 agent who's who
who was guarding it at the time who's
who said he had as much potential as
genius rob lucci but was sent to prison
because he lost the fruit that's how
important it was to the world government
furthermore we know shanks likes to
avoid conflict if possible just think
about how he avoided conflict with the
mountain bandits and would later stop
kaido from attacking whitebeard and even
how he'd stop the paramount war so the
fact that he actually attacked the
vessel guarding the gumgum fruit which
as we know would later be revealed to be
the sun god nika fruit suggests to me
that he knew the truth behind the fruit
otherwise i doubt that someone like
shanks would want to antagonize the
government for no reason so now we
finally get to romance don the first
chapter of the one piece story yes it
took us this long to get to the first
chapter but if you do appreciate the
thoroughness of this video then
definitely don't forget to drop a like
anyways in chapter 1 of one piece we're
told one year ago a pirate ship made
this village its base we see kid luffy
who's just classified as a village boy
at this time and he's determined to make
the red hair pirates take him seriously
he takes a knife and gives himself the
scar he has below his left eye to this
day notably shanks has his three
blackbeard scars at this point also over
his left eye so luffy might have
actually been inspired in part by that
as well maybe it's just a one-piece
thing but it seems like a lot of strong
guys have scars around their eyes
shanks's crew goes on to toast luffy's
courage they love their booze and they
love their meat and they love to party
as well we even see lucky roo downing a
whole barrel of beer shanks chastises
luffy for hurting himself but luffy just
says he's not afraid of getting hurt and
wants to be taken on shanks's next
voyage luffy says he wants to be a
pirate too shanks continually
discourages luffy from being a pirate
which may be a way of him making sure
that this is really what luffy wants he
tells him he can't be a pirate because
he can't swim he doubts luffy when luffy
says his punch is as powerful as a
pistol keep in mind this is before luffy
eats the fruit the rest of the crew are
having a great time and yasoop usop's
dad even says let's just have a good
time as he dances with the others
between the dancing crew members we find
out that they value staying calm having
a good time exploring islands and seas
and best of all having freedom shanks
tells them to stop filling luffy's head
with their crazy ideas and when one
suggests taking luffy with them shank
says only if one of them stays behind
and then the crew members apologize to
luffy and give up trying to convince
shanks thus it's clear from the get-go
that shanks calls a shot and that he is
doing everything in his power not to
romanticize the pirate life to luffy
it's ironic because shanks tells luffy
that he might let him join him on the
ship in 10 years but shanks was an
apprentice way before he turned 17. so
clearly he is being overly cautious with
luffy this may even suggest that there
were some darker moments that shanks
experienced while he was an apprentice
pirate that made him unwilling to take
luffy to see too soon but this hasn't
really been shown yet since he was
usually calm and having a good time when
shown on roger's crew shanks offers
luffy some milk and then laughs when he
drinks it saying a real pirate would
never drink milk ben shanks's first mate
is the one who explains to luffy that
shanks is doing what's best for everyone
he emphasizes that being a pirate is not
all fun and games and that the safety of
the entire crew rests on shanks's
shoulders ben says there's lots of other
pirate duties like pillaging hostage
taking heavy drinking and swimming funny
that he described heavy drinking and
swimming as a duty and in general how
little these descriptions match the
pirate luffy eventually becomes but it
could be a clue that shanks's crew is
not above pillaging and hostage taking
even though it would be weird to see
luffy doing something like that it's
interesting how ben sort of encourages
luffy to keep his dreams alive by saying
that shanks knows that the sea is
dangerous and can kill you in a thousand
ways so that's why he's discouraging
luffy not because he wants to crush his
dream that being said you can tell
shanks clearly likes to laugh and joke
around a lot to the point that luffy
gets annoyed at him shanks even says he
loves making fun of luffy while people
like makino go along with it when luffy
wants her to put his drinks on his
future treasure tab shank says don't try
to swindle the lady in my view he's
pushing back so that luffy will only
become a pirate because he really wants
to and not because he just has a skewed
romanticized view of it because of
shanks although i must say shanks's
behavior would definitely make me want
to prove him wrong so potentially
whether shanks is aware of it or not he
might be strengthening luffy's
conviction with his dismissive you can't
do it attitude shanks tells luffy he's
been using this village as a base for
about a year and after two or three more
voyages they'll leave for good and head
north luffy obviously doesn't want to be
separated from them and says he'll learn
to swim so that he could potentially go
with them but shanks just tells him to
do whatever he wants i think those words
are the key to shanks's behavior towards
luffy he like roger and future luffy
values freedom and wants luffy to make a
free choice the infamous mountain
bandits come in and it is at this point
that luffy has grabbed the gum gum fruit
or the sun god nika fruit and started
eating it no one notices right away
though this is another legendary scene
because it takes on so much significance
once we find out how strong the red hair
pirates and shanks actually are this
mountain bandit leader is so
inexperienced that he calls this crew
which has to be one of the strongest a
sorry lot of pirates higumad abandoned
wants barrels of grog but the red hair
pirates emptied the place and makino has
no more liquor shanks being the stand-up
guy he is feels kind of guilty he
apologizes and offers him an unopened
bottle the bandit breaks the bottle and
spills its contents on shanks the mount
bandits are smiling and the red hair
pirates get serious probably waiting for
a cue from shanks as to how he wants to
deal with this the bandit then brags
that he has an 8 million bounty so
shanks shouldn't mess with him of course
we know that later shanks will be
revealed to have a bounty over 4 billion
which is like 500 times higher than
higuma's now yes this is earlier and the
red hair pirates probably weren't as big
of a deal yet at this point compared to
what they'd become but let's not get it
twisted they were still a really big
deal and shanks had already had his epic
duels with mihawk duels that whitebeard
the strongest man in the world and the
closest to one piece was impressed by
and couldn't help but remember so i love
how oda repays rereading here because
this scene which might have been
frightening the first time you read it
is now hilarious and oda was probably
laughing while drawing this already
thinking of how fans would react to it
down the line during re-reads this man
who impressed the strongest man in the
world already looks like a sorry excuse
for a pirate to this mountain bandit who
keeps acting like a big shot everything
i just said also makes us look at
shanks's reaction here completely
differently as well shanks doesn't stand
up for himself or fight back he just
apologizes for the mess asks for a rag
and says he'll clean it up the bandit is
still not satisfied he takes out his
sword and causes more damage with it he
says if shanks likes to clean that
should keep him busy for a while then he
leaves acting like a big shot and
calling the red hair pirates cowards
makino asks if he's hurt and shanks says
he's fine no harm done he gives us a
sigh of relief which might be read by
the uninitiated as him being glad the
mountain bandits didn't choose to kick
their butts although he's probably just
relieved the mount bandits didn't make
the red hair pirates have to kill them
the whole crew laughs knowing how
outmatched the mount bandit was and they
joke with shanks saying he got you good
shanks laughs too and only luffy is
upset he's angered that the bandit made
shanks look like a weakling he's angered
that shanks didn't fight he says what
kind of man lets himself be treated like
that then laughs about it he calls
shanks a disgrace to pirates harsh words
but shanks just smiles and tells him
when he grows up maybe he'll understand
the mountain bandit just got some grog
on him that's all needless killing
doesn't make you a man and angered and
unconvinced luffy storms off saying he's
going to find a real role model shanks
grabs his arm to hold him back but it
stretches instead to everyone's shock
shanks is finally filled with emotion
and panic for the first time the rest of
the crew including yasuo for freaking
out saying he couldn't have lucky looks
at the chest saying it's not there the
gum gum fruit they took from that enemy
ship we later find out as mentioned that
it was a government ship that was being
watched over by cp9 agent who's who
because the red hair pirates lucky roots
specifically stole the fruit husu was
imprisoned that's how big of a deal this
fruit was and again there's some
speculation as to whether shanks and his
crew knew it was the sun god fruit and i
really think they did why else would a
guy who works so hard to avoid conflict
confront the government for random fruit
furthermore lucky shows luffy a drawing
of the fruit suggesting that they were
looking for it specifically and it was
very special to them otherwise why draw
the fruit you already have that's not a
practice we've seen often yeah they call
it the gum gum fruit but even if they
knew the truth why would they want to
spread everyone else so that more people
want to steal it it makes sense that
they'd still call it by the fake name
even while realizing how big of a deal
it is that it's just been eaten he tells
luffy he'll become like rubber and he
will never be able to swim for the rest
of his life he then calls luffy an idiot
but despite how valuable that fruit was
they leave luffy anyways to grow up in
the village a while after the pirates
went out to sea luffy is talking to
makino she asks if luffy misses them and
he says not after those bandits
humiliated them he says he misjudged
them he thought they were brave and
tough but really they're a bunch of
wimps makino knows what's up saying are
you sure maybe sometimes it takes more
courage not to fight then the mount
bandits come in and take luffy luffy
despite what he said before still cared
about shanks a lot and stood up to the
mountain bandit when the latter insulted
shanks shanks shows up and epicness
ensues shank starts off with a joke as
luffy's head is being stepped on saying
luffy i thought your punch was as
powerful as a pistol gotta love this
dude's sense of humor shanks and his
crew keep approaching even as the
bandits threaten to kill them if they
get any closer a bandit even points a
gun to shanks's head while akom shanks
says matter of factly you're putting
your life on the line by pointing that
at me i'm saying it's not safe to point
guns end quote then suddenly lucky takes
out the bandit with a headshot he
doesn't even stop eating showing that
these guys don't even need to take this
seriously everyone except the red haired
pirates is shocked and some bandits even
say that it wasn't fair ben tells them
to stop whining they're not dealing with
saints here shanks says that i quote
we're pirates and we don't play by the
rules a bandit angrily tells him this is
none of his business but shanks says
listen up you can pour drinks on me you
can throw food at me you can even spit
on me i'll just laugh that stuff off but
good reason or not nobody hurts a friend
of mine end quote i like that addition
of good reason or not further
emphasizing it's not about objective
justice per se it's about as a pirate
doing what you want to do and living by
your own code ben then goes on to take
out all the bandits instantly except for
the leader even extinguishing his
cigarette in one bandit's eye although
they are slow to anger it's awesome to
see how unforgiving the red hair pirates
can be once someone crosses the line a
surprise luffy can't help but remark wow
he's strong when he sees what ben has
just done the leader then says but the
brat started it to which shanks responds
doesn't matter there's a price on your
head isn't there the bandit is real
scared and worried now he throws a smoke
bomb and manages to escape do not ask me
how he managed to escape from such top
tier fighters the bandit decides to hide
out at sea thinking he's a genius
because the pirates will never expect
that he no longer needs a hostage so he
kicks luffy overboard it's at this point
that we get the flashback revealing that
luffy started the fight because he
wanted higuma to take back what he said
about shanks since he called him
pathetic and a coward luffy was very
angry and screamed out stop talking bad
about shanks back to the present and
luffy is in the water a sea king eats
the bandit along with the ship showing
the dangers of the sea and how much the
bandit underestimated it the seeking is
approaching luffy who of course can't
swim and shanks makes it just in time to
save luffy conquer hockey using shanks
just tells the sea king to get out of
here and the seeking obeys shanks then
smiles apologizing to luffy he says
makino told him what happened that luffy
stood up for him shanks says to luffy
hey stop crying you're a tough guy
remember but luffy can't help it and
points out that shanks's arm is gone it
was eaten by the sea king now how did
someone so strong managed to lose his
arm maybe he was just too late and
didn't have time to do anything else
another theory some people point out is
that he wanted to show luffy the dangers
of the sea so again luffy would become a
pirate because he really wanted to and
not because he romanticized what it's
like or at least that he wouldn't take
it too lightly an arm and specifically
shanks's sword arm seems like a big
price to pay just to teach luffy that
lesson but whatever the reason shanks
lost an arm and more importantly he
didn't even flinch he even says that an
arm is a small price to pay and he's
just glad luffy's okay the dude that
lost an arm is comforting the kid he
saved what a complete legend of a role
model shanks is then we're told by the
narrator luffy understood why shanks
wouldn't take him out to sea the dangers
of the sea were too great and he was not
yet strong enough but most of all luffy
realized what a great man shanks was he
vowed to be just like him one day we
then jump to shanks taking off from the
village for the last time luffy says
he's sad but also that he won't ask to
go with them this time he's decided to
become a pirate on his own shank still
teases him saying it wouldn't do him any
good he's still too little he says
there's no way luffy can become a pirate
but luffy says determined oh yes i will
he says one day he'll have a ship and
crew better than shanks's and they'll
have the biggest horde of treasure in
the world luffy proclaims i'm gonna be
king of the pirates shank smiles saying
hmm you're gonna be better than us huh
well then do me a favor keep this hat
safe for me he then gives him the iconic
straw hat he got from roger he tells
luffy this hat means a lot to me
promised that you'll give it back to me
someday when you've become a great
pirate ben remarks that luffy is gonna
make something of himself and shanks
agrees saying he acts just like shanks
did when he was a kid and then 10 years
later luffy set off and beat back a sea
king with a gun gun pistol showing he's
ready for the dangers of the sea finally
unlike that bandit after the first
chapter's heavy focus on shanks the rest
of the series is very scarce with the
shanks moments but that only makes these
few moments all the more exciting and
hype the dark king rayleigh lets us know
that he ran into shanks at sabodi
archipelago soon after shang sacrificed
his arm for luffy and gave luffy his
straw hat and shanks talked to his
former crewmate about luffy
enthusiastically saying there's a kid in
the east blue saying the exact same
thing as captain roger the very same
words the captain said six years after
the armed sacrifice at 33 shanks would
become one of the yonko so it definitely
wouldn't make sense to assume this dude
got weaker after losing his arm at some
point ace also came to thank him for
saving luffy shanks at first is serious
as he'll be with mihawk but then can't
help but smile when ace mentions he's
luffy's brother shanks announces they'll
have a feast and that ace is welcome
there shanks wants to hear ace's
adventures at moments like this it feels
really obvious that luffy is the new era
joy boy when you see how much shanks's
face brightens up when he's mentioned
shanks is always a presence in the story
sometimes it's just characters
mentioning him like in chapter 18 when
buggy mentions to luffy that they were
apprentice pirates together this is when
we get the flashback of shanks saving
buggy's life and buggy blaming him for
foiling his grandiose plans of getting
all the treasure under the sea by making
him accidentally swallow a devil fruit
it's during chapter 96 after luffy's
gained a 30 million berry bounty and
gained the title of the meanest man in
the east that we see shanks in the flesh
again mihawk comes to an island where
shanks and his crew are camping he
thinks that camping on this island is
careless again suggesting how carefree
shanks can be relatively speaking at
first the two are serious when they meet
shanks greatly says i'm in a bad mood
you here to challenge me mihawk responds
he doesn't challenge one-armed has-beens
this is a reference to their previous
duels before shanks lost his good arm
and it kind of makes sense that mihawk
doesn't want to challenge shanks anymore
since if they were so close before he
probably assumes there's no need for
them to fight if shanks doesn't have his
good arm there's also the fact that it's
a lose-lose outcome for mihawk if mihawk
wins everyone can say shanks didn't have
his good arm so that's why mihawk won
and if mihawk lost it would be even more
humiliating that he lost against shanks
after shanks lost his good arm i'm just
going to briefly mention the
controversial possibility that mihawk
could beat shanks one on one in a sword
fight that is at least an argument that
can be made given the handpicked details
the story gives us but that being said
shanks is much more of a threat because
of his crew and ben beckman specifically
may even be of the same caliber of
shanks himself so mihawk could never
hope to actually overcome the red hair
pirates and even a fight with shanks
alone may still be pretty close clearly
close enough for shanks to be willing to
accept the challenge when he's not in a
bad mood at least future events will
also make it harder to believe that
shanks would lose in a fight against
mihawk as we'll get into later anyways
long story short mihawk isn't there to
duel shanks like before but to show him
luffy's poster because it reminded him
of a story shanks told him long ago
about a boy in some village we then see
shanks smile saying so you're here luffy
it's then revealed that he was in a bad
mood because of a hangover but now he's
happy as can be and wants to drink more
to celebrate he says how can i not drink
on a day like this he invites mihawk to
join them and drink too so here we see
that shanks has a close relationship to
zoro's goal namely the greatest
swordsman of the world mihawk and people
may argue that shanks has to be stronger
than mihawk because shanks is luffy's
goal while mihawk is zoros and luffy is
a protagonist after all but to be fair
shanks is not really luffy's goal since
shanks is not the pirate king if you
have to use this logic it's more
accurate to say that goldie roger the
pirate king is luffy's goal so based on
that there's no reason mihawk couldn't
be stronger than shanks theoretically up
to this point in the story at least
aside from the fact that we all hype up
and love shanks but more on his strength
later it's funny how shanks finds
himself talking about luffy to anyone
who will listen from rayleigh to ace to
mihawk in chapter 234 shanks tried to
warn whitebeard about blackbeard through
a letter but whitebeard the strongest
man in the world insisted that if he
wanted something shanks should come in
person with good boos shanks thought
this might happen and agrees to sail for
whitebeard's base beckman asks won't the
government try to stop us and shank says
maybe but we're going anyway we'll deal
with them when the time comes end quote
and his crew is ecstatic that they're
going to fight this is a hype moment as
shank shows he's clearly not worried
enough by the world government to let
them affect his actions and he's down to
deal with them and fight them when he
has to during chapter 433 the five
elders get news that one of the four
emperors red haired shanks has broken
through their lines and has finally made
direct contact with whitebeard the elder
shone looks quite worried and then we
jump to whitebeard and shank's actually
meeting this is classic shanks he will
try not to make trouble by doing
something like sending a letter but when
it's not enough he'll attack world
government fleets if necessary this is
why he had to know about the truth
behind the gomi or else it's just very
out of character for shanks to attack
the government without reason even his
breaking through world government lines
was only done in order to negotiate with
whitebeard about blackbeard and prevent
future more serious bloodshed marco
tells all newcomers to stand back or
they'll get knocked out this is a
reference to shanks's immense
conqueror's hockey people start fainting
juzo remarks that those who have a weak
will can't even remain standing in the
presence of that man meaning shanks who
clearly has some of the strongest
conquerors haki and one of the strongest
wills in the game as whitebeard pirates
faint all around it's pointed out that
as always shanks's hockey is
overwhelming even the wood on the ship
snaps because of his presence shanks
says you'll have to excuse me i have
trouble staying relaxed when on an enemy
ship which implies that when he's
relaxed he's not giving off such hockey
which makes sense maybe he wasn't strong
enough to do it back then but now the
mound bandits would definitely faint
because of shanks's hockey alone again
shanks emphasizes dialogue over combat
saying there's something we must talk
about to whitebeard this is when
whitebeard mentions shanks's apprentice
days with buggy and shanks's legendary
duel with mihawk he says there aren't
many who speak of the legend anymore
your duel with hawkeye is still fresh in
my memory everyone was surprised beyond
their imagination when you came back
from east blue missing an arm whitebeard
wants to know what enemy took his arm
but shanks just says he gave it up for
the sake of the new era again very hyped
that shanks's duel with mihawk made such
a lasting impression on the strongest
man in the world shanks tells whitebeard
he's fought countless battles and
received countless scars but only one
still aches and he says it's the one
over his eye he didn't get it from
mihawk but from blackbeard as we know
aka from whitebeard's own teach another
crazy detail is that shanks emphasizes
it wasn't because he was careless shanks
a usually carefree guy is very serious
right now explaining how blackbeard laid
low and waited for his chance he didn't
even rise up to become a squad leader or
make a name for himself he hid himself
behind the shadow of whitebeard and once
he had enough power he finally made his
move a man like that will never be
satisfied he'll keep aiming for the top
with his own will shanks tells
whitebeard that one day blackbeard will
aim for whitebeard's seat and looking
back his prediction couldn't be more
right not only has blackbeard taken
whitebeard gianco position he definitely
wants to become the strongest man in the
world as well back to the meeting and
shanks says he wants whitebeard to stop
ace great advice and a lot of stuff
could have been avoided if whitebeard
actually did succeed in stopping ace
shanks knows ace is strong but he also
knows it's not the time to put those two
against each other he tells whitebeard
not to go after blackbeard that's his
only request and it makes sense
since it was part of blackbeard's plan
for ace to go after him and for
whitebeard to follow suit whitebeard
refuses because blackbeard broke the
code by killing a crew member and in
doing so killed one of whitebeard's own
children in his view he has no choice
but to show teach that he can't live in
this world without a code of conduct he
then says shanks is 100 years too young
to tell whitebeard what to do shanks
says no one will be able to stop this
new era from spiraling into chaos the
two clash with their weapons and the
heavens split above some think war may
have broken out but marco assures them
shanks isn't the type to do something
stupid again shanks is portrayed as a
very rational character one that's not
likely to randomly or rashly fight as if
the shanks moments weren't already epic
we later hear from the marines that
shanks got involved in some minor
clashes in the new world and these
clashes included none other than kaido
one of the four emperors of the sea
kaido was trying to take advantage of
the current situation to kill whitebeard
and so shanks interfered the marine
hyped up to yonko even more by saying
gravely who can stop a fight among the
four emperors thereby implying that no
one could it's noteworthy that shanks
does succeed in intercepting kaido the
so-called strongest creature in the
world and he succeeds in getting the
strongest creature to turn back while
shanks himself shows up to marine ford
without a scratch the appearance of
shanks is epic as can be too as he saves
kobe's life from akainu's punch with his
sword the block doesn't rattle him at
all as he simply goes on to say that
kobe did a good job for better or worse
the courage he displayed profoundly
influenced the fate of the world we also
see kobe falling with foam in his mouth
one could argue this was fear from
thinking he's going to die combined with
exhaustion but he looks a lot like those
people who previously collapsed on
whitebeard's ship because of shanks's
conqueror's hockey so whereas soon to be
fleet admiral akai news hockey didn't
make him pass out shanks says
potentially did which wouldn't be
surprising based on past events this
dude just stopped a kainu's attack like
it was nothing after making kaido turn
back before i wasn't sure why kaido
turned back and i'm still not but based
on recent events in the story it's
likely that shanks is more of a threat
and stronger than people know especially
after kaido lost to luffy it really
makes me wonder if kaido's higher bounty
and reputation for being the strongest
comes from his emotional personality and
rashness compared to shanks's more
low-key and pacifist ways i mean if the
mount bandit thought shanks was a weak
coward it's possible that everyone else
is underestimating him as well in
moments like this where he clearly won
that dispute with kaido in one way or
another by getting him to turn back
while shanks himself continued to
marineford hints to the fact that he's
probably stronger this is further
supported by the fact that his true
strength has been held back so far while
we saw what kaido was capable of already
and it wasn't enough to beat luffy
shanks's protege in a sense as further
praise for shanks during the kaido vs
luffy fight kaido pictured the scant few
capable of fighting him and among them
was odin
roger whitebeard zebek and of course
shanks so yeah clearly the implication
is that kaido wasn't stronger than
shanks and at the same time you got him
putting shanks in really good company
along with goldie roger and whitebeard
so high praise high praise back to
marineford though shanks says he's come
to put an end to this war we even see
ben beckmann get some screen time as he
pulls his weapon on admiral kisaru and
tells him not to move during moments
like this it definitely feels like
shanks's commanders like beckman are
stronger than kaidos were considering
how easily another admiral namely
admiral greenbull recently overpowered
them and keep in mind this is all
pre-time skip and chances are like luffy
shanks and his crew could have gotten
stronger after the time skip as well the
marines at marine ford point out how he
had a scuffle with kaido only yesterday
so they are shocked he's already here i
absolutely love how he gives future
yonko buggy d clown the task of
returning luffy's straw hat to him and
even tells buggy he has a treasure map
for him as akainu mentions is shanks
that allows luffy to escape so he's not
only strong enough to ruin the plans of
kaido but also to ruin the plans of the
marines buggy is furious when he finds
out that shanks didn't actually have a
treasure map and then he expresses his
frustration to the yonko as if they were
still just fellow apprentices buggy's
followers are blown away by his attitude
toward one of the yonko and just gain
more respect for buggy mihawk just
leaves when shank shows up saying he
never agreed to fight him i love that
detail i think it's him not wanting to
go back on his previous view of fighting
a one-armed shanks but also more
importantly because he doesn't want to
fight his friend to help submarines
again shank says that he doesn't want to
fight it would only lead to more loss of
life on both sides but if anyone still
wants to fight the red hair pirates are
down he even calls out blackbeard
specifically asking him if he wants to
fight but blackbeard passes saying it's
not yet his time to fight shanks this
matchup when it finally comes will be
epic but clearly even blackbeard isn't
confident in being able to beat shanks
at this point even with the strongest
paramecia fruit now in his control
shanks told everyone to retreat and even
said he'll take whitebeard and aces
bodies so the government can't make
spectacles of their deaths even though
the government would obviously want the
bodies to illustrate their power fleet
admiral sengoku gives in to shanks's
command shanks's presence and the
presence of his commanders alone was
enough to end the war which was also
called the greatest battle of the great
pirate age later we see marco thank
shanks at whitebeard and ace's graves
for making it possible for them to get
proper burials at this point shanks
contemplates how hard ace's death must
be for luffy and thinks to himself you
grow up and become a man by experiencing
victory and defeat by doing difficult
things and shedding tears it's all right
to cry just overcome it then we enter a
bit of a shanks winter where we don't
really get anything until a cover story
for chapter 838 where we see shanks
reading the news of luffy's new 500
million bounty after dressrosa and
smiling after whole cake island we again
see shanks reacting to luffy's new
bounty of 1.5 billion and his new title
of the fifth emperor he smiles
commenting that it looks like they'll be
meeting soon thus the implication is
that unlike a marine ford luffy is now
very close to fulfilling their promise
of meeting again when he becomes a great
pirate on a side note after defeating
kaido and gaining a 3 billion berry
bounty and becoming a yonko it's
definitely about time for 19 year old
luffy to meet 39 year old shanks who has
the highest known active bounty right
now at
4.0489 billion berries since kaido and
big mom's bounty became inactive after
their defeats so shang split the heavens
with the strongest man in the world he
exchanged legendary blows with the
strongest swordsman in the world he made
the strongest creature in the world
change his route and he stopped the
greatest war because no one not the
strongest marines nor the strong pirates
present wanted to mess with him by the
time chapter 907 came around you'd think
that shanks could no longer surprise us
but he does in a big way he gets an
audience with the five elders and
marijua not only do they not chase this
yonko out of the capital of the world
government they arranged time to meet
with him at shanks's request that's the
kind of sway this dude has he can meet
with the five elders the highest world
government rulers aside from imu in the
world government's capital we know he
came to talk about a certain pirate but
we never learned who that pirate was at
first everyone thought it was blackbeard
since he went to whitebeard to talk
about him then when luffy was revealed
to be the sun god nika people speculated
shanks might have been warning them
about luffy and his fruit mostly the
evil shanks theorists thought it was the
latter but if shanks knew luffy would
have to die to awaken the fruit that is
possible no matter how unlikely that he
told them so that they could ensure
luffy awakens the fruit then most
recently after the reveal that buggy is
now a new yonko people are speculating
that he could have been talking about
buggy setting him up as a potential
yonko candidate for the five elders new
theories will continue to spring up as
new developments take place in the story
but just the fact that you can get an
audience with the highest powers that be
in their safest of places as a pirate is
insane it could be because as they
revealed before he's not one to cause
trouble and arguably because of his
peacemaking role they might see a lot of
value in cooperating with him however
there's also speculation that he could
be a celestial dragon and that's why the
five elders would meet with him even
though he's a yonko leave your thoughts
for why you think shanks can talk to the
five elders when he wishes to in the
comments either way he's clearly
confident enough in his powers if he's
willing to walk into enemy territory
alone like that it might even be a bit
of a smoker not chasing dragon situation
where they know they can't get him even
if they tried so they don't try another
hype detail we learned during chapter
928 is that kid who now has a bounty
equal to luffy's of 3 billion lost his
arm in a battle with the red hair
pirates now we don't really know if this
was shanks ben beckman or someone else
who took his arm but it goes to show how
epic shanks and his crew are even saying
he lost an arm to them raises his street
cred a lot as we look back we can see
why shanks is such a hyped character
he's introduced as a guy who lets people
walk all over him but turns out to be
arguably the strongest living character
in one piece and is currently the one
with the highest known active bounty and
yet he led a dude who bragged about
having an 8 million barry bounty make
fun of him because he wanted to avoid
unnecessary bloodshed oda has made it so
that every one of the few times shanks
is shown or mentioned it's in a very
hyped way it's come to the point where
oda could just show him in a panel doing
nothing in a new chapter and we'd go
crazy over it although i think people
underestimate mihawk's level i would say
based on the newest developments that
shanks is probably the strongest pirate
in one piece at the moment although
blackbeard and luffy are fast
approaching and it's definitely
reasonable to argue that luffy could be
stronger since he did beat the strongest
creature in the world and the guy people
bet on in a one-on-one fight but like i
explained the fact that we haven't seen
what shanks is capable of yet even
though we know he was able to clash with
kaido and get his way he was able to
stop the greatest war and he was able to
walk into the holy land during the
reverie without fear it all points to
him being a more powerful force than the
already defeated kaido and big mom since
i want this to be a pretty comprehensive
video about shanks let's also address
the character's obvious connection to
the norse god tier and what that
parallel can tell us about shanks's
likely future tyr was concerned with the
formalities of war like treaties and
justice clearly paralleling shanks's own
role as peacekeeper in the story in one
case tyr placed his hand between the
jaws of the monstrous wolf fenrir so the
other gods could trap him when the other
gods tricked fenrir the wolf bit off
tyr's arm this sacrifice is why tyr is
identified as a one-handed god just like
shanks is the one-handed yonko who
sacrificed his arm to a sea king in
order to protect luffy they are both
represented as brave figures ready to
make real sacrifices for their own
ideals tyr's fate during ragnarok was to
slay and be slain by the wolf garmer who
is called the greatest monster garmer
has also been connected to the greek
mythological dog cerberus before
cerberus is often portrayed as a
three-headed dog which may make you
think of shanks's greatest enemy in one
piece blackbeard the yonko with three
skulls on his pirate flag the final
battle between shanks and blackbeard has
long been foreshadowed and built up
shanks fears blackbeard more than any
other as he warned whitebeard and only
the scars blackbeard gave him still her
shanks even at marineford blackbeard
said it's not yet the time for them to
fight but that in and of itself implies
that there will be a time for them to
fight down the line i do believe that
shanks will eventually fall to
blackbeard whether he's killed like tyr
was or is simply defeated remains to be
seen but then luffy will come in to
finally finish off his greatest rival
blackbeard perhaps like with tyr and
garmur shanks will in some way help set
the foundation for blackbeard's defeat
at luffy's hands and as in the myth both
will help take each other down in the
end and luffy and buggy will be left to
rule as the pirate kings let me know
your thoughts on all this and is there
anyone out there who still doesn't think
that blackbeard will fight and defeat
shanks i'd honestly be pretty surprised
if that doesn't happen in one way or
another oda could even make it so that
blackbeard cheats in some way and
defeats shanks without necessarily
proving he's stronger than him that
would after all be a very blackbeard
thing to do anyways smash that like
button if you appreciate this long video
it's like the only video i can remember
that i divided the recording between two
different days so definitely smash that
like button if you enjoyed this vid on
one of the most hyped characters in one
piece the character who went from being
bullied by a petty mountain bandit to
becoming the most wanted man in the
world if i did miss any more details
drop them down below in the comments so
we can all check it out join the nakamot
by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates now is not
the time you want to be missing one
piece because real soon as shanks
himself said he'll have his reunion with
luffy unless blackbeard gets in the way
first if you're a real one and stay
tuned to this all the way to the end
then i really appreciate you and drop a
hashtag all hail buggy in the comments
or at the end of your comment just let
me know you watch until the end again i
really appreciate it this was probably
my second longest video ever and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
in all the yonko warlords supernova and
more link to that is in the description
and on screen right now and until next
time see ya space cowboys